meetings live now
good afternoon everyone and and welcome
in person
uh this is a momentous day as we move
back towards
some semblance of what we used to
laughingly call normality
welcome to this meeting of the
stratford-upon-avon district council
cabinet
my name is darren pemberton i'm the
deputy leader of the council
and i'm chairing this meeting in the
absence of the leader today
so i'm just going to move through a
couple of pieces of haste keeping before
we move to the meeting cabinet members
when you are invited to address
the meeting please ensure your
microphone is switched on
with the red lights in front of you so
that it can be picked up via the live
audio feed when you've finished
addressing the meeting
please turn off your microphone
immediately
those uh please also ensure that you
have switched off
or at the very least on to silence any
other devices that you may have
with you that may interrupt the
proceedings
this meeting is being live broadcast and
members of the public not in attendance
physically today
are able to view the proceedings
so we do have some public speakers in
attendance today for various items on
our agenda
speakers you will be given a 30-second
warning time during your speaking time
once you have finished speaking members
may wish to ask you questions
so please remain at the desk until you
are asked to return to your seat
and when you are speaking please again
can you ensure that you press the large
button
uh in front of you with the uh sort of
speech uh the mouth and speech marks
in front of you to switch the microphone
on and when you have finished speaking
please ensure that the microphone is
switched off having more than one
microphone on at a time
um does cause problems for the system
and will make it even more difficult for
any
body wishing to watch the meeting
remotely
so i'm just going to move to the agenda
now
but before doing so i'm just going to
clarify the amount of speaking time that
i'm going to allow
in the ordinary course of events we
allow three minutes speaking time
on each item i have in conjunction with
officers
concluded that there are items of
significant public interest
and i'm prepared to allow a total time
of five minutes for speakers
i believe we have two speakers one
and that speakers for the public i may
add speakers on item
seven and on item five
so now we move to the agenda um do we
have any apologies for absence
we do we have apologies from councillor
jefferson
thank you disclosures of interest before
you all kick off i will i will ask for
noting of
all letters to cabinet emails to
cabinets on item number seven but i'm
aware that
every single member of cabinet indeed
every single member of the authority
has received correspondence so i think
if you can take that as
noted rather than for every single
person to go through that any other
disclosures of interest counselor harvey
thank you leader for the sake of
transparency and for the purposes of
item
four playing pitch study i'd like to
announce that i am a member of stratford
sports club
squash section
thank you councillor harvey councillor
juned
again for transparency on item seven
i i am a trustee of warwickshire
wildlife trust
it's a non-pecuniary interest and i
presume that any
any any intervention by yourself
counselor junior will be in your
not in your trustee capacity thank you
councillor jennings
just for the sake of transparency on on
item five
although it's not directly relevant i am
uh
um on the board of bid
thank you councillor jennings councillor
ralph i see your hand
uh technically we're taking from members
of the committee and observers but i
will if you wish to note an interest i
will happily have that recorded for you
councillor ralph
okay thank you you preempt my own noting
of
correspondence um in relation to uh
from stratfor town football club uh and
i think if any other member of cabinet
has had similar correspondence can we
note that please
move to item three which are the the
minutes
um any comments observations
dare i say grammatical editions
counselor harvey
could he be clarified whether bishops
itchington
is spelt with an apostrophe or without
my information is it is spelt with
and i will always defer to councillor
harvey in matters of this type
if noting if we can note that amendment
with that amendment noted uh anybody
else i'm looking for a
proposer and secondary to well i propose
accepting the minutes with that
amendment councilor para your seconding
and counselling okay so with that minor
amendment
um uh then uh the the minutes
will be signed and confirmed as a true
and accurate
record of the meeting held on the 12th
of april
under part a mata's referred to council
there are none
i'm now going to move to part b
matters for decision by the cabinet it
is my intention to move
the agenda around somewhat principally
to
accommodate the fact that there are a
number of members of the public
who i imagine have an interest in
item number seven and it would be my
intention to bring that
mata to the beginning of the agenda
i will then be looking to take item five
then next the markets
and then move to items um
six uh which is the stratfor town
football club
uh uh sorry items four and then item six
they're playing pretty study and then
stratford town football club
um in that order if if members of
cabinets are
are comfortable with that so let's now
move to
item seven in your agenda papers which
is uh for the benefit of
probably page 67 of your agenda papers
now before we come to the consideration
of this
item members of cabinet i must advise
you that this authority has received
a letter by email at approximately 11am
this morning
from a firm of solicitors acting on
behalf of the unincorporated
local residents association friends of
fisherman's walk
um making uh
that was received as say at 11 am
members of cabinet
it is absolutely clear that you must
have sight of and consider
the contents of this letter in order
that you can come to a full
and transparent consideration of all the
items all the issues surrounding this
particular
item the letter is seven pages so i'm
proposing that we are going to take
a 15 minute adjournment uh where in
in confidential and private session away
from the cabinet room
you will be provided with a copy of the
letter um our legal officer
will be on hand um to assist
in any uh questions that you may have
around that
so members of cabinet i would ask if you
would all adjourn to the members lounge
uh observers to the meeting uh
councillors june and o'donnell
um you are you can you are to intel you
are to attend as well as observers to
cabinet
so i'm now i'm now going to have an
adjournment it's 20 to 4
and i'm proposing that we will be coming
back at five to four thank you
okay cool
thank you very much uh cabinet members
and thank you very much for your
forbearance members of the public
and for anyone watching the live
broadcast
um just to give you a little bit of
context um members of cabinets have been
considering a seven page
uh letter uh so i apologize that it did
take us a little bit longer than i
yeah than i anticipated so um members
have had the opportunity to consider the
correspondence that
as i say was forwarded to us at 11 a.m
today i'm now going to call upon phil
grafton
the head of governance and democracy uh
just to
say a few words in relation to that
correspondence thank you very much
yes thank you chairman so just for the
public uh to understand that the letter
suggests that um the public consultation
carried out to date
is flawed and that there should be a
second round of
public consultation my legal advice to
cabinet is that
further public consultation is not
necessary
and therefore that the cabinet is quite
at liberty today to make a decision
on the recommendation in the report
if any further legal advice is required
i'd suggest that we
go into private confidential session
otherwise if you're content with that
summary advice
the suggestion is that you might want to
invite the public speaker
uh to speak now and then the report
author tony pertz can maybe pick up on
points raised by the speaker and with
any other aspects
of matters that cabinets are interested
in thank you
thank you mr grafton and in light of
that legal advice
as chair i am comfortable that we
continue with the item um so the item is
the stratfor upon avon riverside project
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
ask our speaker
to to come to the desk i think i have mr
bennis who is uh
indicated uh that he he will speak um
and then
um i will get uh the officer mr perks
to uh to present the item
yes
you press the button in the middle it
lights up and
let me know when you're ready and we'll
start the clock
uh mr bennis
yeah thank you chair and members ladies
and gentlemen
and
it certainly is and has been a long
journey for us all
regarding this wonderful grant that
we've got of
1.5 million who in their right mind
would not want to have 1.5 million
of taxpayers money given to their
community
and certainly would hope that they would
do
the best they could but unfortunately as
you
and as members
have read of the enormous
anxiety that's in our community
regarding this urbanization
of our small community that we have
and this imbalance
that's between the tourism
and the natural way of life we have with
our wildlife
certainly the balance is overwhelmingly
tipped in favor of
of human intrusion
and imposed recreation
that simply does not readdress
the existing my life that we have and
i noticed this morning and thank you
members
for coming up to see for yourself
some aspects of the northern section
my thanks to tony
for taking his time this morning but you
know
we have a wonderful community and we're
very lucky we've got a wonderful town we
gotta
it's people are are so are so
passionate about it and as i said at the
start of my conversation who would not
want 1.5 million
plus another 300 thousand from the
authority
of taxpayers money however
what the government wanted us
you to do does not in any shape or form
represent the plan that we have at the
moment
and i don't wish in any way to go over
what your good selves have
have heard and have and have
read that we are vermintly
vehemently opposed to this
plan as it is at the moment and by the
way
we're not nimbies
we're not people who think well we we
don't want these things of course we
want we want to embrace
everything we have in our community
we're very fortunate we're very lucky
but i would just plead with members to
please
embrace us please embrace the community
and its wildlife and get that balance
that as you mr chairman
said had a conversation with the
conversation
this is a big ticket event this is not
something that's
you know it'll be gone and you know to
be forgotten about
this will impact everything
that we in a community have strived to
keep even for myself 40 years on the
river
rescuing animals looking after wildlife
we will destroy it and we can't afford
to do that because
nature has its way of doing things and
we can't impose
and i'm asking and i'm pleading
on behalf of our community not to impose
a plan that is not acceptable
to our community and i do believe that
we're not being unreasonable
at all we're not being unreasonable but
we are passionate
and mr chairman
you know 1.5 million would go a long way
and i'm sure other members in their
community would like to have 1.5 million
it's not that we don't want it mr
chairman we just want to feel that we
can
get the balance get the value
and above all to keep
our identity our community
and that beautiful landscape that we
have on the northern section
mr chairman i'm just about finished as
an irishman finishing five minutes mr
chairman that's pretty good
i finished thank you mr bernice clearly
not your first rodeo
am i done no you you may or may not be
done
um members of the cabinet um would
anybody like to ask
any questions of of mr bennis
at all counselor kettle
mr bennett have you or your group have
they actually presented
an ecologist report uh which we have had
access to
well um thank you uh councillor offhand
as i sit here i i really can't answer
that i'm
i have we
yes i i believe something well it's a
good question
and i would be very happy to address
that maybe
i'm not sure if you if you don't know
the answer that's i don't know i'm just
waffling here mr chairman and i know
i would not want to waffle mr chairman
[Laughter]
i'm afraid i'm afraid that i i'm not
allowed to be taking
uh okay to turn it into a public meeting
i do
i do understand your desire to to become
involved but we do have to
root this through through through the
speakers thank you thank you
um did i see mr did i see
mr perks yeah i was just gonna if it
helps the cabinets or the citations
referred to
from the back of the room which was sort
of summary of an ecologist used was one
i showed you in the cabinet earlier
today so
you you've had sites of that okay thank
you thank you so much
okay so just for for clarity um
that is that is information that the
cabinet does have before them thank you
thank you mr ben
does anybody else have any questions
uh councillor junior if you've had
information on the ecological survey i
would like to be able to have a copy of
that at all if that's possible
i i understand this information had
previously been circulated
um but i am sure that mr perks can
furnish you with a copy in fact it looks
as though he's got a hard copy he can
furnish you with now
is that correct mr perks yes unless i
need to refer to it to answer any
questions later so i might need it back
[Laughter]
and and for the benefit of the members
of the public a counselor unit is an
observer
to the proceedings not a decision maker
so in terms of
just clarity about that report that was
discussed it's been made available
previously and today to all members of
cabinet councillor junet
i wonder whether i could also ask um
bearing in mind that i am a trustee of
the warwickshire wildlife trust but i
i will not refer to that i'll talk to it
through my own
um um specialisms
um i would like to know what the
nature of reserve designation is sorry
whether it's possible sorry council
ginger it's questions for mr bennett so
you can pick that up
further on so if anybody has questions
for mr bennis
that's what i'm trying to pick up at the
moment so um rather because there will
be an opportunity for further questions
around
uh mr perks presentation okay so i'm
looking around the room um
mr bennis thank you very much for your
presentation
um thank you so what we'll now do is um
thank you members uh we'll present the
item
uh and then we will get into discussion
and debate
and questioning a councillor junior
there will be then that opportunity
to enable you to to raise that question
work directly yourself with the officer
mr perks
you councillor pemberton i just thought
i might share my screen so as people can
see the slides we don't necessarily need
to see
them but it does give you the structure
of the presentation so
i'll just start them through um
thank you for the opportunity
oh yeah certainly can everybody here
okay
um thank you for the opportunity to
speak today uh normally this
item would have been introduced by
councillor jefferson but obviously
because he's um
a way i i'm i'm going to introduce it
for you
um i just wanted to run through a few
slides to make sure that members have
got all the information that you need to
make an informed decision and hopefully
this supplements the information that
i've put into the report today
um i'm going to start with just a quick
reminder that in june 2020 we had the
opportunity to sort of make a bid to the
getting building fund initiative
which is administered by the lab and
that the sort of
the purpose of that that bid was to look
for projects that sort of allowed sort
of towns and economies to recover
stronger after covid
it looked at sort of sort of economic
growth and community rebuilding
it's probably worth sort of bearing in
mind that um with our
tourism basis of our economy and our
dependence on the automotive industry we
were
put down as potentially the fourth
hardest sort of hit economy within the
uk
so it was in that context that the bid
was put together
um and we we came up with a scheme that
went out for public consultation that
sought to sort of use um
our blue and green infrastructure sort
of an open space
based bid to try and support residents
and locals sort of getting back out and
also to bring visitors into the town to
support the economies of the businesses
within the town
um what we found particularly sort of
last summer sort of in the
brief respite from covert that we
enjoyed was open space was
really a key driver in getting people
out getting people happy to
leave their homes and sort of get things
going again
we've had an aspiration alongside the
stratfor town trust who are sort of
owners of part of the
site we're talking about today to do
something to improve
the public access to warrant road lands
we felt that the area had been sort of
neglected
over the years and there was an
opportunity to do more with it um the
town trusted explored various options
and
we so we had a dialogue with them that
was going on
and based on these and the plans that
we'd consulted on sort of in 2017 to
sort of improve the recreation ground
we should combine these two ideas to put
together the bid that went
in which was based around the riverside
corridor and using that to regenerate
the town
it was received very favorably by the
lep um and it was seen as potential for
a blue
a blueprint for other recovery of other
riverside towns stratford was
seen as a front runner in that they were
hoping to see what they could learn from
it sort of deploy in other areas
and we were awarded as it's been
mentioned one and a half million from
the lab
and half a million of match funding
between which is split between us and
attained trust
um the proposal basically sort of
increases access to sort of open space
to the blue and green infrastructure
which is responding to a lot of the
research that's been conducted to the
post pandemic about the public demand
and the idea was it sort of using what
stratford's got the beautiful river the
sort of countryside around the entrance
to stratford
to sort of secure the economic future of
the town getting people out and about
again getting people
sort of enjoying being outside and
supporting some of the businesses in the
town center
we saw some proposal that diversified
what stratfor had to offer this theater
has been dark
for well over 12 months now which has
taken the heart out of the
the town we felt that in sort of growing
back stronger we needed to make sure
stratford offered more than
just theater and it was diversifying
what
our marketplace um and hopefully
through this this sort of project we can
secure sort of some of the employment in
the time that's dependence on some
people being out about
and using the center one of the other
sort of key
desires from the project was to sort of
increase accessibility
for everybody to make sure the space was
available for common use
that people could enjoy it we're looking
to improve disabled access
and make that sort of generally more
usable so
running through sort of what we've done
we put we we'd already done a
consultation on the recreation ground in
2017 which would
have sort of been accepted so building
on that we
appointed a firm called node who
produced a concept plan
for the wider area it picked up the
proposals from the south that had
already been consulted on and extended
them to cover the lynch's meadows in the
central area
and they came up with the sort of a
parkland concept
and we tested sort of a significant out
of town car park
thoughts behind that was it would reduce
congestion sort of on the gyratory and
improve air quality if we could stop the
traffic
coming into the town by the m40 traffic
sort of pulling
pulling in there and we put that out for
public consultation
um the back end of last year and that
concluded the end of january this year
it's one of the best public
consultations i've ever done to be
perfectly honest it was a really
valuable exercise often you put
sort of stuff out you don't get a lot of
response
and things don't really change i think
what i really liked about this
public consultation is we learned an
awful lot about the site that we didn't
know when we started it
it was a combination we put a concept
together we put it out for consultation
at the same time we were doing sort of
surveys of the site and trying to
build our own understanding of it but
between
the two efforts we generally i think
have moved the scheme on a lot as a
result of the consultation that we did
the key points coming back from the
consultation was there was very little
support for our idea of the car park on
the edge of town
people just didn't want it so um we
we've dropped that there was also a lot
of information provided to us
including the citation that was
mentioned earlier about sort of what was
underneath
the sort of the the land that we see
there now the fact that there was a
nature reserve that had been constructed
a few years ago
it had sort of fallen into disrepair but
a lot of the infrastructure was already
there um and the reports that was
provided to us sort of gave us
sort of a basis for sort of restoring
that sort of biodiversity
um what we did then was we collated all
of the comments we had them
professionally analyzed
and we published all the redacted
comments on
the project website and we also produced
a you said we did document to show how
the updated scheme
would reflect the comments that we we've
received um
following the consultation feedback and
the analysis we've now
reflected on that and we've produced a
revised scheme which is what the
concept of which is before members today
for your opinions um
in terms of what's changed we've quite
radically changed the way we deal with
car parking
um as i say there was very little
support for the large car park on the
edge of town
there was a lot of support for making
better use of the leisure center car
park so
in the new proposal you'll you'll notice
that the nature reserve
now looks sort of both ways so as you
can make better use of the leisure
center car park you can go from the
leicester center carpark into the nature
reserve
rather than always sort of coming
through towards town
um we do still feel there needs to be a
small
increase at the fisherman's car park
because we have over demand for that car
park at present
and if we attract more people to use
that area particularly if we want people
to use the boats
swimming area which there seems to be a
pressure a natural pressure coming from
the sort of public to do that following
cobia
we feel it would be sensible to expand
that um
i think we're now suggesting up to 75
spaces in that area rather than the 500
we initially consulted on um
we're very much now committed to
providing a nature reserve sort of
solution to the lynch's meadow
um as i say we've learned a lot about
the site and we feel that we can
um diverse for what shropshire has to
offer by the provision of stratford
nature reserve
serving the town um and one of the
things i would
seek your views on is whether members
would like some of us to seek some sort
of designations of protection to that
possibly local nature research status or
something like that i
value steer on that today
um the updated proposal also commits us
to sort of look at the feasibility of a
link road between warwick road and the
leisure center car park that was
something that came out quite strongly
in the feedback that people felt
that would be valuable it's not within
our gift to do entirely we need to do it
in consultation with the
county council and we'd also need to
find some budget to do that
but um what i have done when i've
already started work on this is
consulted the county council and we're
looking at whether we can get a
feasibility study put together so we're
ready for another round of
funding bids as and when they arrive
the scheme that you've got today before
you is a concept scheme
we presented the revised updated concept
scheme to the lep board
last thursday because one of my concerns
was this was quite significantly
different to what we originally talked
to the left about
and i'm pleased to say that let boards
have signed this off that if we do the
nature reserve-based solution that will
still comply with the grant conditions
and they're happy to continue with the
funding agreement
so that was a a good thing from my
perspective
um the scheme as i say is concert scheme
at the moment it's obviously subject to
a lot of statutory approval still we
will need
planning permission for a lot of the
work we're trying to do we'll need to
consult the environment agencies to the
further we will need supply weights
consent for some aspects of it
um at this stage we've consulted all of
the relevant agencies we've had quite a
lot of dialogue with the environment
agency in the county council
who were supportive of the principles of
it but i haven't taken that two parts at
the moment i'm just asking you to agree
a concept
and i don't want to spend a lot of money
on design if it's a concept that you
don't fundamentally support
um really coming to the conclusion now
the reports also at the back end of it
contains sort of a breakdown of work
packages and a high level sort of budget
for the
the project that is slightly over the
budget that we have at the moment but
we'd like to sort of
if members agree the concept package
use that as the basis for developing a
tender exercise to
drive some sort of value in some value
engineering work to make sure that we
remain in budget so in terms of the next
steps we're here today
sort of looking for a steer as to
whether it's a proposal you want to sort
of move on
with we've got ongoing survey works and
impact assessments i've kept those
running because a lot of those are
seasonally dependent a lot of
the animal and so the floor and fauna
surveys have to be done at certain times
of year
we're on a tight spend deadline with the
lap here so i've made sure that we we've
kept that going so as we don't
lose the feasibility we've started some
early work in the recreation ground some
of you may have seen the play area that
we've constructed there that was
previously consulted on and were due to
start work on the cycle track in early
june
um if we um receive your blessing today
i'll
start work on some of the detailed
design packages which we'll sort of
share with you as the project goes
forward as we start to sort of
deal with some of the issues that we'll
have to face
i think it's fair to say that funding
never covers everything that you want to
do so we need to sort of have a
mechanism in place to agree what the
priorities are of the scheme going
forward
and we'd like to keep engaging with you
as
the project develops and just a reminder
in conclusion that we need to have
completed the spend of the let money but
not necessarily the match funding
by the 31st of march 2022.
i think that's all i wanted to say
hopefully it's a useful introduction to
you
thank you very much mr perks um
questions from
members of cabinet and i'll come to
observers as well questions from
anyone at all please
i will have some questions but i will
defer i think councillor junit actually
did get before you on the basis that
she'd started to ask her question
uh before we got to this section
councillor o'donnell i'm sure you'll be
happy to uh to afford her first
first go if i might
uh ask two questions uh one is uh i'd
like to
with the uh approval of the chair of
ovue and scrutiny
perhaps have a look at the the
consultation process but i'll leave
that for the chair um to outline
but my second one is that having a had a
quick look at that
the document and also knowing about the
local wildlife survey in 2020
um there was clearly in that uh that
this was a nationally endangered
mg4 nvc um floral um
community there that was had it was an
area that
had had 25 years of neglect
uh and was you know it is critical that
that
is preserved as much as possible and the
recommendation i understand
and this is where my question comes in
is that there should be
a local nature reserve designation
is from the experts so i would hope that
the cabinet would take that seriously
and seek a local nature reserve
designation
is that is there a question there for or
is that you are you looking for a
response from cabinet
for mr question is will will um will
that be taken
um you know that will the advice on a
local nature reserve designation be
be sought and taken um seriously
so thank thank you very much councillor
juned um
i think that uh my understanding is that
historically and
uh it was grade four status and i think
it's sort of
grade one status now which is actually
um
not particularly uh it's degraded quite
considerably and i
and my understanding is that our
aspiration is that
um we sort of we get back to sort of
grade four status
and i think investigating and certainly
i am minded
if if if cabinets are minded to support
the recommendation
um to give a steer around continuing to
work towards
whatever is the most appropriate status
uh for the site
but i think mr perks did you want to
just come in there
um yes i'm i'm happy to come in you're
right
the mg1 mg4 um designation comes from
the
citation that was provided to us and the
warwickshire county council prepared
it relates to part of the northern part
of the site which was sort of a meadow
which had degraded from mg4 to mg1 grade
um we're committed in the scheme to do
what's necessary to reinstate that
you'll write some leader and
the point on the local nature reserve
i'm very happy to explore that
my only slight reservation is there are
some restrictions on what
size things have to be but i'm very
happy to sort of investigate that in
more detail and report back to cabinet
if you'd like us to
thank you before going to councillor
o'donnell councillor junid
also talked about overview and scrutiny
looking at the consultation process and
i would like to get some advice
from mr grafton uh given the
correspondence that we've received today
about that might be a question of
timing
um just to be clear if just to help
i'm not sure i'm seeking advice on
whether
there should be a scrutiny of something
that potentially subject to
a legal process at that point so maybe
it's a
and after the event
yeah well you'll have heard me say
earlier but i don't think that a
second public consultation is legally
necessary
but but in terms of other scrutiny going
forward by the osc
um that that would be encouraged
yes sorry i think in all fairness to
counter junior were you in the room when
phil gave the okay so i thought we
sorted that out to be honest um can i
just make a comment from osc
around this rather than a question um so
as chair of occ i'd just like to
reiterate my thanks to tony for when he
came to
to our committee on our minutes but he
just been published today
so it's just to really reassure cabinet
and also members of the public that he'd
give a really detailed presentation at
our meeting
taking a number of well-thought-out
questions from members now our main
points discussed by osc were the
finances of the project
car parking provision feasibility study
into the link road
from warwick road to the leisure center
car park and the use of section 106
monies
planning permission requirements
discussions with local business owners
future public consultation
and how potential increase in visitors
to the area would be managed and he
answered all of those
thoroughly and reassuringly and the
committee recognized that the amended
proposals had responded to the feedback
from the original consultation and we
emphasized and i think this is possibly
what council juno is picking up on
that moving forward the council should
work hand in hand with local residents
and stakeholders to get the project
right
some members of the committee were also
keen for the council to investigate
options for tennis courts etc as part of
the scheme
but pending the outcome of today's
discussions at osc will continue to
scrutinize the project as it develops as
we would with any big ticket
item to ensure the council takes
advantage of what could be
a very exciting opportunity for our
district so it's really just about all
ideas coming together that's what we
picked up at osu and that covers all of
it doesn't it counselors
it it our job as opening scrutiny is to
hold
the cabinet and the council to account
and what we would
like to do is seek assurance that we can
do that role
on this particular project thank you
i think i can absolutely categorically
give you that assurance on this and
any other project i think my only
concern was
around if uh if if given
um there is correspondence around timing
around some of that so that's
that not at all looking to fetter um
and my as i understand it there is a
project board already in place
um that mr perks will will be sort of
working hand in glove with should
cabinet be minded to
accept the recommendations i would also
anticipate further updates
to cabinet and that would that would
trigger timing i would suspect for
further input from overview and scrutiny
at the appropriate
checkpoints um but i'm sure that's
something we can work through and so
that you can ensure you have
the right and proper overview of this as
mr bennett bennis did accurately recall
that in a conversation we had i did
describe this
as a big ticket project because it is so
just to clarify it will be as
as when we have our forward planning
program meetings one of the items that
we can call back in counselor juniors so
it's an ongoing organic process as it
were thank you for that reassurance
absolutely absolutely
so anybody else with any questions
counselor cargill i think did you
did you indicate i did but it has been
explained i think because it was the mg4
to mg1
and my only other part question to that
to counter to mr folks was
how much time and effort would it take
to get to mg4 for example that was
that was it but i think in fairness
that's a detail and i'm quite happy for
it to
come through the the the normal process
thank you chair
counselor kettle
um thank you mr chairman um
mr perks um there have been a number of
concerns raised in the correspondence
we've received
some of which relate to conflict between
different existing users
um and how they will be impacted by the
changes and i think one particular area
were disabled
fishermen and i just the first question
is
can that conflict be managed going
forward so that those who currently use
the
river for whatever they're using for and
swimming clearly
can continue to use it when the project
is complete
um do you want to answer that first i'll
come up with a more substantive question
second if you don't mind
thank you councillor kettle it's
certainly my intention that everybody
should be able to use the river at least
as well when it's finished as they can
now and hopefully better if we get this
project right
um i have taken the liberty of starting
to arrange to engage with the over
navigation trust
discuss the details of this sort of next
week sort of
depending on sort of what the outcome
today is but you're right what we're
seeking to do or the project team is
seeking to do with this is
is balance the interest of the river
so that well taking your specific
example of the sort of
the fisherman um there is a significant
chunk of money
in the project that can sort of be used
to improve sort of fishing pegs
if that's gets signed up here we would
seek to engage in detail with the
levington anglers association with the
concession holder on that bank and work
out sort of how the best way of
delivering that is
i have to admit to not being an expert
in phishing so i would i would seek to
work with them
and the other interest groups around um
under the tutelage i suppose of the ava
navigation trust you have control of the
aviation to try and sort of negotiate
the best solution that we can sort of
going forward for everybody
thank you mr my second point
and this goes i think on the roadside
project runs
an awful long way but much of the focus
uh and particularly the lesser we've
received
it is all about the lynch meadows um i
think it would be quite helpful just to
have
know exactly on the map which is the
lynch meadows which
um because there was quite a there was
an area between the leisure center up
towards
um and beyond the existing car park um
is there any definition of whether lynch
meadows is
are my interpretation of where the lynch
meadows
um sit is i don't do you have the plan
in front of you counselor kettle
yeah okay
if if and anybody else who happens to
have it
if you see the hotel in the center of
the drawing
um there's a sort of horseshoe of water
and a numbers 2 and 20.
i've generally accepted that anything to
the north of that is what people are
referring to
as as lynch meadows so it is the entire
northern section yes it is eventually
yeah i i've seen the projects into the
three sections the northern section
which
is the lynch meadows there's a southern
section
based around what we slightly
poorly called the hot cross bun um the
bridge at the round the back of the
crane plaza
and then the recreation ground in the
southern part um the the other side of
the river there so
the lynch meadows is is the northern
part of the plan yeah
thank you mr folks that was really just
for clarification
but i think the sort of principle issue
that seems to be coming out of the
correspondence we've received
um is about the negative
impact on the biodiversity of
the um of the what i now can describe
as the lynch meadows um
and you talked about um it's fairly low
grade at the moment the intention is to
improve that
could you talk us through how the
ecologist
thinks that can be achieved um
given your much more detailed knowledge
on this area because i think that is the
crutch
if it's going to make it worse there's a
there's a problem if it's going to
enhance biodiversity
then clearly well not for my colleagues
consider
but my view that would be a good thing
yes i think i can answer that um and i
will
probably take my lead from the the
citation provided by sort of watch
provided by warwickshire county council
there that sort of formed the skeleton
for the updated
um scheme that we're proposing for you
today um
and as i shared with you the 10th page
10 includes a number of recommendations
of how biodiversity could be improved on
the site
and that includes things like um
restoring the mg4 meadow
it includes sort of laying a network of
official parts
includes restoring ponds including
eradicating invasive alien plant species
and generally sort of improving sort of
habitats um
one of the things we'd like to try and
do is introduce the reed bed to try and
solving
improves and improve the wetland
habitats in the site and the ecologists
are of the view that this is it's a site
that can be improved it has a lot of
natural value at the moment
but there are opportunities to improve
that as seems to be suggested in the
report that we've received on it
not everything that we're proposing will
improve biodiversity on the site um
the big area that has attracted
attention with that which i don't shy
away from
is the car park extension
producing a car park will have a cost in
terms of biodiversity
the way we've attacked that is we've
asked our ecologists well
if we had to provide a small sort of car
park what is the least invasive way of
doing it where are the areas of
that it would potentially cause least
harm and that has informed the design
that we've got we've had some advice um
as recently as friday from the warranty
wildlife trust on this where they
they say that actually if you do a sort
of informal service on the car park and
you put some hedging around it you can
actually improve sort of nesting bird
habitats
and the putting it where it is we're at
the moment it's
like a nettle area not particularly high
quality
um landscape or whatever the right term
is
um that it will still be a car park but
it'll be
it could minimize the ecological damage
that it does to that
now if we choose not to provide any sort
of car parking at the top of the site
and we're looking to attract more people
and i think we have to question our
responsibilities of a
public sector body that we would be open
criticisms why
why we didn't sort of make a provision
for car parking as well as at the
southern end and most of the logic
behind that
is that a lot of people are using the
the bathing place now we have paddle
boarders we have
people who choose to sort of go to that
end of the site
um we and i i think we
need to economic accommodate them in a
sensitive way which i think is
what the updated scheme proposes
so hopefully that's picked up your
points
final point i will ask any more
final point though what management
of the lunch meadows has historically
taken place
over say the last five or ten years
um little or none to my knowledge
um
council harvey thank you chairman i'm
looking at the ecologist report and i
note that
um they specifically talk about
the open habitats of slowly degrading
through
lack of any form of management the
scheme would provide
easy wheelchair access because it's
restricted
to the paved area around the river
at the moment it would provide an
excellent site for introducing
people to the natural world given the
vast change that's been made
to the scheme from what was initially
proposed
as a basis consultation and what is now
in mind
um would you say it's a fair criticism
to say suggest that the council has been
negligent in not having pursued this
earlier
far be for me to get us into trouble
with the law but um
yes the the management of the nature
reserve over the last 20 years has
fallen short of i think certainly what
would have been ideal
[Music]
cancer cargill and then i think i have
councillor shenson
thank you chad no okay councillor
cargill thank you chad um picking up the
point
that councillor harley mentioned about
accessibility
uh will this scheme actually improve
accessibility
in in over the whole scheme when we're
not talking about
you know from the north and right the
way down to and we'll just stick at the
top of the car park
sorry the hotel from the moment and the
second
and this perhaps isn't fair but do you
have a feel for how much actual hard
development
this scheme would do as a percentage of
the entire castle cargo can you
talk to the microphone i think some of
us are struggling to hear you
sorry it's i'm i'm interested to know if
mr burch can actually give us a a feel
for the actual hard development i.e the
car park
um for example and any other um metaled
uh roads or foot piles etc as a
approximation of the of the site in a
percentage terms
or not uh thank you councillor cargill
picking at your first point around
accessibility
we are seeking to make um this area more
accessible so for everybody as i said
that was a key drive for the project and
it's
one of the key principles for behind the
chain trust involvement as well
um i i don't have a plan to point to on
the screen but
there will be sort of two key arteries
in the northern part of the site will be
sort of
accessible which is the main sort of
accessible cycleway footpath that runs
through the center
and the existing path along the river
will be made accessible
currently when you get to the back of
the crowne plaza hotel there is a bridge
that's sort of
very inexcessive it's very steep at the
moment we are seeking to replace that
with an
accessible bridge that allows sort of
access for the boats into the
the crown plaza loop but also improves
access for sort of wheelchairs sort of
buggies push chairs
and all that type of thing and there's
another small but smaller bridge to be
upgraded over one of
the tributaries um further along the
side
not as the scheme stands not every path
within the scheme will be fully
accessible to everybody but you should
be able to get sort of key areas
but we want to maintain the sense of
adventure for sort of children scurrying
about on trim trials and things like
that as well
and we don't want to sort of i don't
want to use any tarmac at all
in the in the scheme if i can help it
but we don't want to sort of over
urbanize it that's what's clear feedback
we've got from the public consultation
that people won't welcome and over
organizing of the space
so we're looking at sort of probably a a
a rolled band gravel sort of path
whatever we can sort of
make least naturally invasive but also
disabled accessible and flood resilient
we've got a piece of work to do there as
a design team to come up with the
surface there
and then the parts off that will be less
formal probably sort of like an unedged
gravel or something like that so as
we're not wearing away the nature
reserve
it's something that we can sort of just
keep trimmed but they won't be
sort of a full metal path like a
pavement
um i did have a slight heads up on the
question that you were asking
for something cancer harvey mentioned to
me when we were walking around this
morning about what percentage are we
sort of paving over in this
so i've had the design team sort of have
a look at that since this morning
looking at the northern part of the site
because i think the southern part is is
probably a different entity um
the total hard standing which comprises
the skate park extension the car parks
the paths and the boardwalk
is roughly um four percent of the floor
area
of the site and of that about one and a
half percent of that is car parking
servicing
that's useful too
thank you mr perks uh any other members
of cabinets or observers any questions
for mr perks
after that i'll get into uh any debate
counsellor juned you mentioned bathing
could i
ask the question has a question gone to
seven trent
about the quality of the water because i
do understand there are problems
in various rivers of sewage uh in rivers
so
is this clean this river
yes we've engaged with seven trends and
started a series of
meetings with them and seven trent
alongside this project
as opposed to as part of it are looking
to improve that section of the avon up
to sort of bathing quality which
involves
some works as i understand it and i'm
talking from memory here now
to two of their sewage treatment plants
further upstream and also
they need to deal with some agricultural
runoff of fertilizers getting into the
water
at the moment the water probably isn't
of bathing quality but people
are bathing in it always have done and i
don't think we have much power to
stop that whilst we don't encourage it
and wild swimming
is something that is very much in vogue
at the moment
but yes we are engaging with seven
trends about sort of improving the water
quality
alongside that okay so i think
it looks as though i've uh we've
exhausted questions
so i'm just opening this up for comment
and debates
by cabinet members anybody wants to go
first
councillor barker
thank you councillor pemberton um it
occurs to me that
a large part of this site has
all has been derived from um
already excavated sand and gravel pits
which have then been used for landfill
it's been managed or mismanaged or not
managed or
left for a period of time at least since
1995 and that
in all honesty to do some work to this
is a massive
massive advantage and i ca although we
need to be it needs to be done
sensitively i cannot see
any problems at all with the scheme
because i think it overall will be an
improvement
thank you councillor barker i've got
councillor
parry cargill kettle
thank you chairman um it was very very
helpful to actually go and visit the
site it's one of those
we've we've all been looking at the
plans we've also had
so many emails of correspondence and
that type of thing
um but i certainly found the site visit
extremely helpful
i am familiar off the site from the
riverside point of view
having been um a keen a keen boater
a few years ago now but i found it very
very helpful to go to that
to go to this to explore the whole
areas and i think what i also found very
helpful was the citation
from the county council and it is
interesting
to hear that the proposed development
only represents 4
of the whole area which to be honest
with you on our site visit this morning
is just complete almost complete
scrubland
and we can clearly see it has been
neglected and deteriorated for the last
25 years
and one can understand why they have now
categorized it as
as mg1 from mg4 status
um and it you know this is a this is a
huge opportunity
that we have i also thought it was quite
interesting
um you know having done the sort of
research and looking at various comments
online
um of course the new county councillor
um
for stratford north was very much
pitching his
election campaign on having
having the site more as the managed
facility and i know he having
he i know from from his comments
that he certainly did a lot of research
on that um
and actually got voted in so that's
that's an encouraging sign
i think the key thing is is about
balance and planning is all about
balance and here we have an opportunity
to enhance and improve what we currently
have
um and i'd like to to actually take this
opportunity to thank tony perks and his
team of staff for doing a very diligent
um and very thorough um
work scheme on the whole of this for the
last six months because i think there's
been no stone
unturned um
and i certainly think it's um would be
of great benefit particularly
for residents um and as a fairly new
granny
i would very much look forward to taking
my grandsons pushing them in a push
chair
which i couldn't possibly do at the
moment so thank you
thank you chair and yeah i think it's
obvious
the passion that people hold for this
particular area and i can't blame them
it's a fantastic place i've been
involved
aware of this project for some time now
and the principle is as is often the
case
well-minded but i do have a concern but
i'll come back to it shortly
first the principle of allowing access
into areas of open space is laudable
and very relevant especially today
when this project came forward i'm sure
as all the cabinet considered the
environmental impact zone of the area
now i'm not an
environment expert so i rely on the
experts and social life but i know
something's not right i got
i can feel it as well as anybody and i
have considered the report from march
wildlife trust
who are broadly supportive with caveats
and i think we all have
caveats in them but i do note that some
residents are concerned
about perhaps visitors oh too many
visitors coming along
and damaging the environment a little
story if i may very brief
during the first lockdown in covid the
woods
near me um which i frequently walk
suddenly became very popular going from
a couple of hundred people
a week to a thousand now i was quite
concerned about that this is overly
woods
which susan knows very well i was quite
concerned about that
i talked with the forestry commission
who are the caretakers of that
because i i was wondering if it was
going to get damaged and overrun
now then i thought when i was inducted
as a counselor
it was impressed upon me to consider the
whole district
not just my little patch so working
with the forestry commission a schedule
of works was implemented
the uh roads were improved
other things during the cycle routes
were off trail
routes were taken out and such like and
the
result is a more welcoming environment
and more people can actually use it
and that's only a good thing in my my
book
there is more littering but mainly
that's dog owners
picking up the dog poo putting in a bag
and throwing on the side of the road
and we're working on that
now wwt state
that people and nature can coexist i
agree with that
and i think that's what's happened with
the woods that were
near where i live so bringing people
close to nature means
they can appreciate and respect it and
they are a next generation
of nature lovers and environmentalists
and we should encourage that as well
so i do believe this scheme should be
this area should be enhanced
sympathetically
uh improved and made available to all
our residents my concern is
currently if we leave it alone we don't
do anything with it it will
only benefit a few and that's not what i
was elected for
as a councillor thank you chair
thank you uh counselor kettle please
thank you mr chairman
i think it's um
we need to look at the whole scheme of
perspective it isn't just about lynch
meadows clearly it stretches right from
the south as i mentioned earlier
over the bridge over the river moving
forward through the wreck etcetera but
the area that is most controversial is
the lynch meadows
and i think what we really have to
understand
is whether land
neglected improves
the biodiversity or whether
land neglected reduces biodiversity and
i think
the the seminal example of this
is the nepa state in sussex
um where
in one respect a headline it was
abandoned
to allow nature to regenerate
uh that of course started off with 350
acres and extended three and a half
thousand acres
and reflected what the dutch did uh
ersta i hope i get the right
pronunciations mr gem erst vader's platz
plus which was five thousand hectares uh
near amsterdam now
what the premises behind
both those schemes was reintroducing
to the landscape what the landscape
originally had
before agricultural industrialization
and that included not only the small
but also sorry mr shenzhen are you
sorry do you need a break
okay what happened there was
the reintroduction of a wide variety of
different species
from large herbivores down to creating
uh or destroying the drainage structure
enabling areas to be flooded in the
winter
without intervention by human beings
but it was precisely that intervention
into that area
that allowed the future non-intervention
to take place
but critically what was really important
to making net the success it has turned
out to be
was the introduction of large herbivores
and i'm talking about large hoverboards
that have a material impact on the
landscape
in terms of um
managing the scrub land managing the
grasses
yeah okay so i'm trying i'm trying to
what
what we have here is an idea that it
should be left alone
and it'll improve but quite clearly
as nep has demonstrated you can't do
things we can't let big herbivores here
mr chairman
because i have to be fenced in and it's
too small so
if we're not going to have the full
diversity that a nature reserve requires
it needs to be managed and what mr perks
has said to us today
is that by managing biodiversity will
improve on this site
and that has to be managed and what he
has said clearly it has not been managed
properly for the last
10 years i think and the report that
came
through was that there has been
significant loss of species
uh from that neglect so i think what
we're going to see here
is by improving the management of that
area will improve the biodiversity
um which will be for the benefit of
everybody
so yes it is always nice to think if we
leave everything alone
it'll get better but it doesn't happen
like that
management is required unless you go
three and a half thousand i think your
point is well made councillor kettle
councillor harvey then councillor
jennings
very quickly um in
encouraging this project we do need to
ensure that we make
uh provision within our finances for
management of this
this project and secondly i draw
attention on page 10 of the report
the the ecologists report that the
current management
of the the area is evaluated as a
c
in need of improvement i would have
thought that if we proceed
we should have a specific objective that
within
five years time or ten years time or
whatever the appropriate period is
that we improve we have the ecologists
back and we we
anticipate that that should get up to a
b perhaps even an a
but certainly an improvement thank you
council harvey councillor jennings
okay i'm a man of few words so i'd like
to thank all the officers
for all the hard work put into the
project so far um in my view this is an
excellent project which will benefit the
whole of the community not just a few
the report here um from washington
county council
urgent work needs to be done it keeps on
emphasizing that and i think we need to
move forward as quickly as possible
thank you thank you i think just to try
and
wrap and sum up um
for um in terms of uh the um
representations made which have been
made
in detail and with passion
i think mr bennis honed in on a number
of areas
um anxiety about the impact
of the scheme on wildlife on
biodiversity
imbalance in terms of its impact versus
human interaction
and
urbanization um and i think all three
of those concerns have been
heard loud and clear
we have a scheme before us
that is significantly different in many
respects to the original scoping
scheme that was put out to consultation
i think it is therefore true to say that
the council and its partner the town
trust have reflected upon
the responses to the consultation and
have acted accordingly
it is quite legitimate for people to be
in opposition to this scheme
or for any other scheme for that matter
um and it is legitimate and correct that
people be
consulted but not necessarily everybody
will get out of the consultation that
wish they seek to achieve
personally i have to say that i am in
favor of the scheme
i do believe that by listening to the
consultation
there have been changes and i do believe
that the officers and the project board
will meet remain cognizant of the
issues that have been raised i do
honestly believe that this is actually
an opportunity to create
a positive benefit and to enhance
the existing resource on the river for
the benefit
principally of our residents i i do see
that in in part of the pitch there is
the question of
tourism i frankly doubt that this is a
project that is going to be pitched
hard in beijing or bradford for that
matter
i believe this is a benefit principally
to the residents of this town who will
have the opportunity for
more access and access in a sensitive
manner to a
resource that we have on our doorstep in
the river and then
and the nature part of that
and we have to set ourselves a high bar
about taking on board the concerns to
ensure that
the future husbandry of this riverside
park reserve whatever whatever name you
give it
at the you know at a principal entrance
through the leisure center
which is a significant change about
flipping the actual
you know the entrance in essence more
through the leisure center car park
than fisherman's um we set ourselves a
high bar about
being good custodians of an enhanced
project
and i think that there is a significant
opportunity for
all residents of stratford to enjoy the
benefits of of this project
and personally i am prepared to
support the recommendation having said
that i would like
some amendments to the to the
recommendation
we have through this discussion um
heard the desire to to explore the
opportunities
for local nature reserve status
uh which i think is governed by the
national parks and access to the
countryside act
1949 um or
some other status as appropriate
as with mr perks i'm not clear on the
strict criteria but i think that
direction of travel towards that kind of
approach
to the particularly the northern end the
lynch's meadows
end of the site i think it's a steer
that we should be
embedded in a recommendation so um uh
members with your with your forbearance
i would be
adding a second recommendation uh that
the council
works towards the lynch meadows securing
um local nature reserve status or
some other such status as
would preserve and enhance the
biodiversity of the site
mr perks is that sort of that seems to
pick up the conversation we've had so i
have that as a
sort of second second recommendation and
a third recommendation
is that um that mr perks uh in
conjunction with the relevant portfolio
holder
engages with the current project board
which includes members of this council
and members of the town trust um and
proactively engages through the overview
and scrutiny process
to ensure that as delivery starts to
unfold on the assumption that uh the
three recommendations are accepted
uh that there is proper clear and
transparent public oversight
of the delivery of the project to
achieve um
the objectives uh that i think we all
seek
uh from that um so members i am seeking
a second
for those two additional recommendations
i see councillor cargill
and have you got you you're happy with
that uh and we'll just clarify
those wordings on that basis i'm prepa i
have a i propose to know as a second
members uh will you raise your cards
uh either in favor of or not raise your
cards if you're a
well first of all those in favor of the
proposition
i take that as as unanimous so the
recommendation
of of the cabinet is that the attached
concept design
and identified scheduler projects is
endorsed and that the deputy chief
executive is asked to develop the
detailed designs and implement the
scheme
within the agreed concept and budget
secondly
that the council should work towards the
lynch meadows
securing local nature reserve status or
some other
appropriate status either under the
national parks and access of the
countryside act 1949 or other
appropriate designations and that
thirdly
the project board uh sorry uh the
deputy chief executive liaise is with
the project board
and provides update to the project board
and proactively to the overview and
scrutiny committee
on delivery of the project as we move
forward
we're all happy with that
thank you very much i'm now going to
uh having uh having moved the agenda
once i
at the request of mr mccrory i'm going
to move the agenda
around a little bit more and apologies
for that we're now going to
if if any members of the public are only
here for the riverside corridor project
and they want to
then i'll give a minute or two before we
kick the next item off
thank you so members we're now going to
go to item 4 playing pitch study
page 9 on your agenda papers
so members this is the lead members on
this are myself councillors barker and
shenton
uh councillor shenton has had to leave
um
this uh this is a report that uh
in relation to playing pitch provision
across the district
uh and and is intended to form the basis
of production for a new playing pitch
strategy
um as with the other item i'm going to
invite our speaker to come
first of all i think mr mccrory would
like to speak on this item is that
correct
mr mccrory if you'd like to come to the
to the chair uh
just uh at an angle in the corner there
um
you can take your mask off when you get
back to your chair thank you
for uh for for adhering to our
to our guidelines and i think you've
just been guided as to uh
how you can make yourself hurt so mr
macquarie you're the
um the owner of stratfor tank is that
correct or the managing director or
what's your
proper title bill payer no i'm the
chairman of stratfor town stratfor
town's still a
community club in the interest so mr
mccrory
um once you're ready you're going to
have up to five minutes um i'll give you
a 30 second heads up
uh towards the end of your time if you
just like to to
to make your your pitch pardon the pun
to the cabinet
uh basically i just wanted to make the
cabinet aware of the
the pps that i've read i have been
involved with
pps's from the football foundation
previously
over nine years and i was concerned that
the
uh the baseline that's been set up
which has been proposed sorry it's just
kicked off
that's been proposed is a priority
document so where it says right except
what's only said to me earlier
that this is uh at stage a which isn't a
consultation of clubs
it actually has been consoled so this
keeps cutting out
it has been consulted of clubs within
the area
and and that's what i want to highlight
that i believe it's a flawed document
okay so is that what you the point you
want to make there mr macquarie so
um any members of cabinet want to uh
ask any question of mr mcquarrie on
on any part of this if not then i'll get
to
mr kirk's to present
and undoubtedly members of cabinet will
actually pick up
your point there so thank you very much
mr perks
uh thank you chairman um yes what i
thought we were presenting here
um prior to mr mccrory's interjection
was a stage a report as
part of our playing pitch strategy which
is sort of a high level study sort of
based around sort of national governing
bodies
input um those of you who've had the
time to
study the strategy in detail um will
know that there are a number of stages
that the report goes through stages a to
e
and we wouldn't generally sort of seek
the views and gather those of clubs
until sort of the stage b
report which we would be producing as
part of the emerging
south warwickshire local plan um within
that we would normally sort of divide
the
the area into suitable sort of chunks
based on sort of travel time and
sporting activity and we would seek to
consult and gather the club's
views at that time to identify priority
projects going forward
um we're at the edge of my knowledge of
it at that stage and i haven't got john
kevin with me to
back me up on the details i as far as i
was aware
prior to seeing mr mccrory uh at the
back this morning no no clubs have been
consulted at the party as part of stage
a
um but um mr corey believes that that
isn't
the case so i would have to take that
away and look at it
on that basis mr uh perks is that
something you would
prefer to take away and to reconsider in
terms of the entire report
or would or do you wish us to continue
to consider the
the report this afternoon um i'm i'm
sort of
comfortable either way if you feel that
there's something that you
need to clarify in terms of ensuring
that you're on all fours as far as the
report is concerned
i'm reluctant to defer the report um for
the reason that it
places us on the back foot when trying
to seek playing for
playing pitch provisions from developers
coming forward but
i would be very concerned if um mr
mccrory's organization was strapped to
10 is a very important club to us
if they were in some way disadvantaged
by it
do you mind if i just take advice from
sort of mr grafton who's back in the
room just for a second
i'm just going to have a quick i could
do a bit of legal advice timing is
everything as mr grafton comes in just
at the right moment in the movie
mr perks would like to see the benefits
of your advice mr grafton
um are we going to do this live across
the room would you
would you like to take a minute to take
separately
if i could just have a quiet word with
bill then i couldn't say
members of cabinet members of the public
with your forbearance
uh i think we'll just let mr perks and
mr grafton
leave the room to for a minute to take
some advice on the point raised by mr
mccrory
before coming back to consider whether
we're going to continue with the item
thank you
as well i was actually trying to well
yeah
so i think mr perks you've had the
opportunity to take some advice
from mr grafton um i suppose cutting to
the chase
uh is mr grafin going to give some
advice about or
or mr perks are you going to decide
whether it's you want to take this now
or defer
yeah no in light of the discussions that
we've had which are very helpful thank
you
um cabinet for alloying with the
adjournment there um
we would like you to debate
adopting the strategy today as it is at
stage a
and the concerns that have been sort of
brought to our attention by mr mccrory
will be addressed prior to the
commencing of the stage b works to make
sure that the
no clubs are in a way prejudiced by any
anything that may come out from that
but the the information you have you in
front of you for stage a we would like
you to endorse if you see fit because
that would be
useful for us in development management
terms thank you very much mr
perks so mr perks um i think you just
started
your presentation or as do you want to
run through
what you need to say then we'll take
some questions
if we have any and then take it from
there i am comfortable based on what you
have said
in conjunction with the monitoring
officer and the assurance publicly given
for mr macquarie and stratfor town
football club that they they will not be
disadvantaged in any way shape or form
uh to take the matter forward i am not i
am conscious that councillor rolf also
wishes to speak
uh no councillor rolfe has indicated
that that's cool
thank you very much councillor rolfe i
think we we moved to you mr perks
uh thank you um chairman um i don't
think i've had a
terrible amount more to say than i i've
said already what you have before you
is the first stage of our playing pitch
strategy
um the overall playing pitch strategy
once completed sets out
the needs of the district in terms of
outdoor sports provision
in in the key sporting areas that will
sort of form part of the local plan
going forward
what you're being asked to sign off
today is the
the stage a of that which has been
prepared by consultants and pps
and um sets out the management
arrangements set up
steering group and project teams and
identifies the study area it's some
fairly high level at this
um at this stage but it does include
some sort of demographic information and
some areas that the plan may need to
focus on once
we move into more detail so i'll leave
it at that
thank you mr perks uh members of cabinet
any questions for mr perks
counselor kettle um mr perks
um i'll try to be more succinct than i
was last time
um you've you've identified
um
uh rugby soccer hockey
uh i'm just trying to find my cricket
and one other than i can't what the
other one is sorry
um you've excluded
there's no reference to tennis or um
any of the things that use a tennis type
call basketball
netball whatever i just wonder why
they've been excluded
and they're still sports provision yeah
the
the playing pitch strategy the the
legislation that guides that
sets out which pitches we we should in
which sports we should and shouldn't
consider
so those are the lists so in essence
it's pitches rather than courts
i think hopefully does that give you the
clarification you're seeking councillor
kettle thank you
the second one was um just like
in the page where you've got the number
of um rugby
pitches i think you've got five uh
three five full size pictures and two
small size pitch three g pitches
um but you've got um
uh a number of the clubs mentioned have
more than one pitch
but you've only you've only got five
pitch seven pictures but you've got
um seven clubs surely that means there
should be rather more than pictures
rugby pictures around
i would have to sort of take advice on
that level of detail to be honest
i'm just wondering if there's an over
focus on soccer and whether there's an
under focus on some of the other sports
which are
possibly a minority or no two of my
cabinet colleagues would disagree with
that
um i think i think uh mr perks
uh is presenting on behalf of uh mr
carefort and
doesn't have that level of detail
although i think the point is well know
that
our pitch provision should ensure that
there is accessibility
and enhanced accessibility for for all
sports
pitches whether they be whatever shape
of the particular ball is involved
councillor parry thank you chairman and
um it's really i'm just wanting to make
a bit of a plea
as the ward member for wells born um
that wells born should also
be recognized as an individual identity
um the wellsborn wanderers
is a fantastic youth orientated
club that has no home no pitches and is
currently
looking for a 10 acre site um
and basically has to to to
play its club matches and training
sessions
wherever it can get a spare pitch which
i know sometimes includes stratford
football club but it has over 30
i think it's got 13 teams of boys and
girls
um and i just would ask that we include
the identity of wells born
as part of the strategy i know the new
settlements
the chairman asked that obviously the
revised pps
methodology should include the revised
um
the new settlements bidford and ulster
just if i may request
that wellspawn is included in that as
well thank you
i think that mr perks hears that loud
and clear and wellsborne will be
included
i mean my observation is that um the the
you know the provision of pitches and
courts when we get to it needs only to
go one way which is up
uh so that we can ensure that we we as a
district enjoy
the uh the level of provision that uh
other parts of the country and indeed
other parts of the world enjoy
so no other questions or comments
any debates or do we wish to go to the
recommendation
i'm not seeing any debate so the
recommendation is to endorse the playing
pit strategy
stage a report so that that be used
alongside the sports facility strategy
to inform planning decisions as such
sorry as appropriate and form the basis
for producing a full playing pitch
strategy
as part of the evidence base for the
south warwickshire local plan
um and of course noting the um the
caveat around ensuring that no
organization uh
is disadvantaged and also noting that um
we will at some point need a court
strategy as well by the sounds of it
uh cabinet members can i can i have your
votes to support the recommendation
that's carriage unanimously thank you
very much
i'll now move to the next sort of sports
related item in the agenda
which is item uh number six stratfor
town football club again it's the mr
perk show today uh mr perks
first of all i think i do have does mr
mccrory wish to speak to this item
very bring yourself forward mr mccrory
and councillor ralph do you wish to
speak as well
i could be flexible i'll be very quick
so i'd like to thank the council and the
councillors for
reviewing this opportunity and i'd like
to explain
where stratfor town football club is
currently and the benefits
it brings to the area the district
we currently have 1200 uh young men
come through the club on football every
week and ladies and girls
we also run a sports education program
which is
taking 60 young adults between 16 and 18
through the club that have minimal ucas
points and we're reintroducing them
back into science society we currently
have a
pass right on education using sport to
bring them back in
at 98 plus distinction
which is an incredible result for the
local kids
young adults we also house rugby
archery youth house table tennis
and we go out to areas like shipston
bedford
welford wellsborn with a minibus to pick
up kids who
are unable to travel to where we are
i'm a big believer and advocate of using
sport or music
to get kids who are hard to reach to get
back into uh
society um and i welcome some of the
comments on the pps
of my beliefs that everyone needs
supporting in the area
because it's some of these kids that
fall through the net on top of that
and it's not the first team that matters
here because it is the community and
that's why
i got involved the first team has been a
success to
and a credit to the community it's had
19 players go through the club since
i've been here
that have gone into full-time employment
and working at a full-time sports level
we've made the playoffs we've won the
southern league cup
and we were third on top this year with
kids from within this community they're
being coached from the levels of four
up we've increased the level of coaching
from normal
level two we now have ua for b uh for
hay
and pro licensing coaches as this club
strives
to get towards the football league but
not forgetting
that i have tried to house the hockey
club where we can i'm a big believer
that astro pictures can be multi-use
and i'll continue to service the uh
community to the best way i can
and i just wanted to make everybody
aware of what stratfor town
stratfor town football club is actually
doing for the community currently
because when i walked in it was a little
bit of a poison chalice
and it is a club in the community now
serving the community
so regardless of the outcome of your
result i'd like to thank you for taking
the time to review
the opportunity for stratford to partner
relaying a pitch for the kids of the
community
thank you very much mr mccory any
questions from mr macquarie before
councillor kettle
uh mr mccrory um
clearly you've got a very successful
operation going in
in stratford how many um
players do you get from uh the east of
the district
southern um penny compton
uh that's the very around there
so from south i'm in the area the other
side of the m40 basically you find most
of them go towards lemington and
obviously with the new facilities
gathering
we recently bought a minibus to pick up
the local
people as much as possible i will try
and get another minibus to
pick up kids on the other side of the
m40
i think to be fair as uh with previous
knowledge of having been a chair of bid
for juniors
mr mccrory is absolutely right they do
there is quite a strong
team and and there is a strong setup in
levington so uh
um it's i think it's not so much about
not
uh supporting the district i think it's
actually the pull
of a different club to i think to be
fair to mr macquarie
uh there i think three years over the
three years we was on the brink of
administration until i walked in
to get where we are now uh with the
support of the people in the room
i'd like to think we'll be making a
challenge for the conference prep
surely any other questions to mr mccrory
no cancer off no
um i am reminded by the chief executive
that as the acting leader i'm still on
training wheels and should have
remembered that this is actually
councillor harvey's item to introduce
and so i have many apologies council
harvey would you like to introduce the
item in conjunction with mr perks
thank you mr chairman this is very
straightforward
there are two legs to this two financial
legs to this proposal
originally this strap was
provided with a loan of a quarter
million pounds
in 2006. the other half of the story
which isn't
reflected in the paper is that this was
part of a
property deal uh to enable another
development to go on
which actually turned out where
the council was it was a case of hedge
you win
and tails you in because uh
but that's another story as far as that
transaction is concerned
the council did very well the practice
uh
put my former uh banking hat on
um this is in in in reality
this is a loan which is granted um
in 2006 where
sixteen thousand pounds or thereabouts
has been repaid out of the quarter
million
um the auditors have already
uh some two three years ago suggested
that we write half of this off
this is a this is a loan which in
reality
should have been offered as a grant
should have been made
as a grant so that in in proposing this
uh
um proposal to write off the outstanding
balance
it is merely a matter of calling a spay
to spay
this is a this is not a loan that's
actually going to ever be repaid
half of it has been written off we might
as well do the the decent thing and bury
it and write the rest off
and the second leg is the 50 000 pounds
and i'm going to defer them mr corey
because
i think he said it all really this is
money well spent
it will serve a lot of people it'll
it'll
it'll provide a lot of benefit to to a
lot of youngsters and
adults uh male and female across a wide
range not just stratford-centric
and so i don't have any hesitation and
we can pay for this
out of section 106 money we have the
capability to do this
and mr macquarie has set out
exactly the sort of reasons why this is
a good use of money for the benefit of
the community in general so on that
basis
i propose resolutions proposals
one and two as set out in the paper
thank you councillor harvey uh any
members of cabinet or observers any
questions
observations okay i'm quite happy to
second this recommendation i think this
is absolutely
the right thing to do counselor kettle
um
i i understand completely where cancer
harvey's coming from and i don't
raise any objections to that if it's
dead it's dead it ain't gonna suddenly
produce
the sort of money is needed um and
clearly the current condition of the
all-weather pitch
demonstrates something needs to be done
but i think we do need to consider
really alluding to the point i made
earlier on that this is a broad district
75 of residents do not live in stratford
um and it is far better to provide local
facilities than be putting children in
buses
or young adults in buses or older
buses i suppose um to ship them into
stratford
there are successful teams elsewhere and
i think we do need to ensure going
forward in the future
that we do support sports facilities
across the entire district
although in this case i completely
understand the background
to this demand and on that basis
happy to to go forward with it and we'll
second it but on the basis that we do
in the future look around particularly
in the east
what facilities are available to our
residents
in those areas thank you councillor
kettle i think you know the
and the vehicle for that will be the
item that we just considered around the
plane pit strategy
i mean i think that many of us go up and
down the country or indeed on
on mainland europe and you know you know
almost every
every settlement worth its name has got
a an artificial
pitch it's got basketball courts it's
got tennis courts and it's got an
artificial running track
and we are significantly behind the
curve
nationally on that and so uh your point
is well made councillor cargill
thank you chair i i've applaud the the
efforts
that have been put into this and
especially bringing the youth together
but i echo cancer kettle's concerns
about
being abroad and right across the
district
as an example ulster town has about 800
youngsters going through its pitches
on a regular basis so again it's a very
very thriving
community but we do need to support all
of those as well
um and then the other thing i was for
for mr perks
is the the 50k built leisure facilities
where is that coming from please what
what is what development
i haven't got a list of developments um
with me today but it would be
developments that um it was appropriate
to spend sort of in stratford
so it would be on the back of stratfor
developments
thank you councillor cargill and you are
not you are noted as being echoed
the point is well made around facilities
around the district and i think
the key driver will be the playing pit
strategy to start to drive towards that
and for us to encourage uh through
through development as we go through the
plan
um a higher higher delivery so
i think we have a proposal in the
portfolio
holder and council kettle as the
seconder
all those in favor of the
recommendations
that's unanimous thank you very much
members of
cabinet so now we move to item number
five which is the
market contracts extension
members that is page
55 of your papers
and um the
lead member introducing this item
is councillor shenton
thank you leader or chairman um
and my apologies for having to leave the
meeting uh
earlier on and thank you for allowing me
back in your welcome return is noted
so at the outset i want to put forward
an amended recommendation
section 5.2.3 is not correct
as the town council has yet to approve
the extension
the amended version should now read
subject to stratfor town council
approving this at their meeting on the
27th of july
2021 the recommendation is that the
current market contract is extended
until the 30th of september 2027
and the new revenue and cost split
arrangement of 50 50
be entered into by the head of service
in agreement with the portfolio
holder so
does anybody want me to repeat that is
everybody comfortable with that
so it really just takes care of the fact
that stratfor town council hasn't
as yet decided on this
the reason why we must consider this
decision just over a year before the
primary period of the contract
expires in september of this year is
that we must give the operator at least
one year's notice if we do not intend to
extend the contract
as the papers highlight on page 58
section 5.2.1
sdc have carried the lion's share of the
cast as we had a 60 40 split
and in reality we have one member of
staff dedicated to contract which we
were not
charging fully against the contract
as part of the recommendation we're
suggesting the 50 50 split of all
revenue and all costs so that we share
any remaining balance equally the market
operator has been instrumental in
host in stratford hosting the national
association of british market
authorities
or nabma conference the national finals
of the youth market run by the
national market traders federation and a
very successful victorian chrismar
christmas market that attracted over 127
000
visitors up to the market over three
days
as well as the charter markets on a
friday
the urban market on saturday and the up
markets on sundays
in addition due to the combination of a
nice looking successful market in an
iconic location
the one show covered the finals of the
youth market in 2019
and virtually a whole live show was
dedicated to present the overall winner
on primetime tv
radio and tv reports on the markets are
regular features as we are acknowledged
as having one of the best markets
in such an iconic location next to the
river raven and the rsc if members of
the cabinet decide
not to endorse the recommendation then
we will need to talk to the town council
about the possibility of reprocuring the
contract
it is highly likely that in any future
contract procured now
the revenue would be less due to the way
many contracts are now set up
however as section 5.2.1
shows revenue does not exceed costs by
huge sums but the
benefit to the town and the district is
that the markets are proven to increase
footfall as the people and places survey
in 2018
clearly demonstrated this is also
acknowledged by a number of the brics
and mortar businesses at section 1.6.2
you will see the results of the survey
run by the bid
over the last couple of months and it
clearly shows that 92 percent of all
members of the bid
either have no view over the market or
support the market
the bid have around 420 members
now if you require that and go into more
depth about the survey
if members wish but at this stage i'll
finish on the survey by saying that we
delayed
bringing this item to cabinet to allow
the bid
time to run this survey
acting leader i would like to obviously
come back to answer any
uh points raised by the speaker but at
this point in time i would ask members
of the cabinet
to approve the amended recommendation
but as always
i'm happy to answer any questions
i think what you're actually asking is
that the amendment to the recommendation
be noted rather than to approve the
recommendation
as we've still to have questions um
councillor junior i know you've got a
question but i would be keen
i understand i have we have mr
halford and councillor fragili would
like to speak to the items i'm just
wondering whether
it might be better to hear from them
first of all unless they're
it it's very specific i will i will i'll
let that guy there
it's 1.5.3 i just want to know when you
became aware that
uh that that that section was not
correct
um it was about well when we when the
papers were issued
i got in touch with committee services
and they advised
that i'd need to declare it at this
meeting
so um that was and it was i know
councillor curtis got in touch with me
yesterday or today
but we already um agreed on the wording
of that
okay thank you um i think now i'll move
to our speakers
i have mr halford mr hoffman if you'd
like to come to
the the the the desk um
you'll have seen everybody already do
this so uh there is a
a large button in front of you when
you're ready to start speaking press
that um you will have up to five minutes
um at 30 seconds out uh you'll you'll
you'll you'll get a heads up that you're
approaching the end
over to you mr hulford
thank you for covering it okay
um i come to you today as a business
owner
an independent business owner in
stratford but i'm also a member of the
bid board
so i just wanted to clear that and i'm
also an ex-market trader
i speak to you today as a business owner
but i have been requested by the bid
board to make a representation on their
behalf
the bid request that the decision on the
market contract be deferred until the
next cabinet meeting
the bid have not had an opportunity to
meet and discuss the survey results
and they have now the opportunity to
make a comment on those results
the bid carried out a survey under
pressure of time to meet the deadline
set by the council and during a period
during that period all non-essential
business retail was closed
and virtually all hospitality venues
were also closed
due to government restrictions my
understanding is that a decision to
defer today is no risk to the contract
but it would show good faith by allowing
the bid to give a considered response on
behalf of its members
me speaking as a business owner my
concern it comes from the wording of the
recommendation
and the how it relates to the contracts
in future constructive conversations
paragraph 1.6.2 mentioned by councillor
shenton
draws the conclusion that as 76 of
businesses did not respond to the survey
during a national lockdown that those
business must have
no view or a positive view um
i i that to me is a wild and
unsubstantiated
assumption it is like saying anyone
not voting in an election must have
supported the winners of that election
the assumption also deflects from some
of the facts held
within the figures that have presented
you today
they show that approximately thirty
percent as almost one in three
businesses feel the markets have a
negative effect on their business that
equates to over 100 businesses within
the town centre
however unlike the record recommendation
i'm not going to jump to unsubstantiated
assumptions
the real story in the comments is in the
comments of the survey
if you look at the survey there's
columns and columns
of comments which is a mine a mine of
data
some of those comments i'll give an
example some of the comments uh some of
the top line information
the rother street market is popular with
traders and in fact they would like to
see more markets
in brother street particularly midweek
to help drive football into the area
the victorian market again is
universally popular and shows the
potential
not just for the victorian market but
for potentially for more regular themed
markets
quarterly monthly the opportunities
there
to be discussed and um you know if we
could take something forward
the waterside market takes criticism as
if it is felt that it keeps footfall at
the lower end of the town
i've spoke to traders in brother street
and surrounding streets
and some say they are forced to close on
sundays due to lack of footfall in that
area
on friday i held a very constructive
meeting with the director of the market
operators
and we discussed various options to help
alleviate this issue
we also discussed further opportunities
for markets and he stated that our only
limit is our ambition
i therefore request from cabinet that
when deciding on the contract whether
it's today
or a future date it is not considered to
be the end of the matter
but comes with a commitment to
constructive
open-minded dialogue between all
stakeholders
the way we can work to alleviate this
way we can
we can work to alleviate the genuine
concerns of some traders
and to utilize the market asset for
further community
commercial opportunity and i thank you
the cabinet for taking the time to
listen to me today
thank you mr halford um any questions
for mr halford
i did get councillor jennings was in
first
[Music]
yeah thank you um i'm awesome on
on the big board and i'm not aware that
you've been given any authority to
comment on their behalf um
i suggest you go through the email
trails um but
i've been asked by josephine if i would
take
lead in future for on all subjects to
deal with the market
for the board and there are also um
a few emails on there asking for me to
make representation on
a um deferment but that wasn't discussed
by the board or voted on
no you're correct it wasn't but i often
asked to do it by members of the board
it's just a mute it is a midpoint i was
prepared to come here today
purely as an independent um business
person
um or with ask for a determinant but i
have been asked specifically by members
of the board too
a problem just following up with um what
councilor jennings has
said in that we had a meeting councillor
jennings and myself with josephine
and lindsey armstrong on wednesday
josephine categorically said
that you were here to speak on your own
behalf not
speak on behalf of the
[Music]
and he wasn't consulted about this is
that correct
that is correct and i've confirmed that
at the meeting that is what said
uh josephine said to us and further to
that you had
you open that was on wednesday you've
had a meeting okay look
members of cabinet i think um i don't
think we can get into a
a a debate what i am going to say is
that i have
i have an email from the chairman of the
board uh the bid board
that does not indicate that you have a
mandate to represent
the bid on anything market related yeah
you have made your points
i think if members have any questions
for mr halford
then please let's address those then i
think if not
we'll move to the ward member and then
we'll move into
questions further questions for the
portfolio holder and or the lead officer
but i think a sort of a sort of to and
fro
i think that what has said has been said
i think that
i think we leave it at that point i
think that's probably the best thing and
i think if we now
ask cancer fragility sorry
you've got a specific question now
that's if there's a specific question
for mr holford absolutely
take that thank you uh mr holton i mean
we know you
can yeah and you still haven't brought
me that drink
and um you filled in the survey
i would guess well i did but strangely
enough my results hadn't appeared on the
survey so i don't know
obviously i would guess that the
the board as you'll remember
did their very best to contact
all the members whose email addresses
you would have telephone
which you would have well i don't know
how up-to-date that
database is and that's one of the things
i'm going to ask the board to have a
look at
as you know we've just our directors
just left
or directed just left and there are
another issues i want to have a look at
again
with threshold i think mr holdwood will
now strain into the management of the
board
the bid board itself i think he's
probably not really
the remit for this cabinet meeting okay
in the absence of any other questions
matt thank you for your
uh for your comments uh mr halford uh
cabinet has heard those
um thank you very much may i ask cancer
fragility to
to come forward and make any
representation that she may wish to make
thank you mr holford
councillor fragile you know the drill
thank you thank you chair
um as ward counsellor for guild hall
in which rotherstreet waterside and
bridge street sit
all from time to time market sites
i've been aware for many years of
concern from some quarters
about the market and its possible
effects on local businesses
and indeed the poor relationship between
bids and market providers
which i think is quite well known i'm
not a member of the market forum
or a town representative on bids i was
asked as ward councillor
to attend a zoom meeting on tuesday the
11th of may
together with councillor rolfe as she is
waterside is in her county council
division
to hear independent business concerns
over the recommendation which is before
cabinet today
the issues of concern centered around
the survey carried out by bid
recently it was carried out during
lockdown where many hospitality
businesses in particular
were not contactable although as uh
councillor shenzhen has said
considerable effort was made to include
all businesses
but many hospitality businesses i
understand couldn't be contacted at that
time
the data collected once more as i
understand
had to be delivered to sdc by a certain
date
for this recommendation to be formulated
but due to covered conditions
this data has not yet formally been
presented to the big board
for their considered view
i understand also that radical change of
personnel is taking place at bed
at this time and that bid should be
afforded
some time to absorb the implications of
this change
the paragraph 1.5.3 has actually been
addressed so i won't mention that
i know that bids and the town council
fully support the well-run and popular
markets in this market town
but bids is requesting a short
postponement of this recommendation
to the next cabinet which i believe
would be in three weeks time because
this cabinet has been shifted on a week
to able
to be able to digest the current changes
that are taking place
and the data from the survey and hold
constructive conversations with the
market forum
for a cooperative way forward i do
understand that mr halford has had a
co-op very cooperative meeting with the
uh
market provider but that's been informal
or not formalized and i do hope this is
going to be an opportunity
for some of the difficulties between bid
and the market going forward can be
resolved because this
town needs positive accepted
and well-performing markets
supported by the businesses thank you
thank you um i have a question
um can you
help the cabinet in contrasting the
ability of the bid
seemingly not to be able to contact its
members on this issue
but it against its ability throughout
most of last summer to contact its
members
around the kobit safety 19 measures and
i from my perspective
those are absolutely the same uh
circumstances that pertain
uh because what you're asking us to do
is uh partly to defer on the basis that
this has been in the two difficult box
as far as
um gaining an evidence base from their
members so perhaps you might like to
comment on
on that i mean as i said as i said at
the beginning
i'm not a member of the market forum
neither am i a member of bids
i was actually asked to go along to this
particular meeting before this
particular
cabinet session to understand some of
the
voices which are of concern
my view as award counsellor is that i
want these markets to be successful
i want the business i want bids to be
successful
that hasn't been the case until until
now
in my understanding from sitting on the
outside of it
i do think this begins to present an
opportunity
to have those conversations to make sure
that bids and the market forum on which
the town council and the district is
represented
to come together to make a positive move
forward
i think if we miss out on this
opportunity to move the markets forward
with bids
it will be a missed opportunity
[Music]
thank you as as ward member how many
people in your ward have
uh approached you and asked you to
uh reject the renewal of the contract
for
the markets i don't think anybody is
asking to
reject this what they're asking for is a
short amount of time
sorry to take many people how many
people have asked me
um i think i i think i've spoken to
i think there were eight people at that
uh meet i think i think it was eight
people at that meeting
so eight out of the two thousand in the
award
well i have a lot of people in my world
who talk to me about the market
i have resident upon resident who say
they like to have the market in bridge
street
i have residents who say they find the
market on waterside
too many of them they quite like the
market on waterside but they find there
are too many throughout the year
i have residents who say they uh they
like the wall
the market on rother street residents in
this town
like their markets but they actually
feel at the moment
they're not quite in balance
thank you i have councillor kettle with
a question for the ward member
um councillor i know full well that
you're
not on the bid board but in terms
clearly as local councillor you do
represent businesses within the
within your ward as much as your
residence um
do you have any feeling for
um the negative effect
in terms of financial on those
businesses
of having markets because according to
the report
we've got out of the 31 who didn't like
it
eight had data but only two were had to
share
it now it's very difficult to have an
understanding
of whether this is having a serious
and material negative impact on their
business or whether it is
uh for other reasons i mean do you have
any handle on this at all
my handle on it really is that
i believe bids is the organization that
represents
and works with businesses in this town
to make sure that they
are well informed and that the market
works for them
as well as for for for the residents and
i think
as we all know over the last few years
that hasn't really been the case there
have there have been difficulties
i'm not totally sure exactly what those
difficulties are between the two
organizations
but i'm aware of it among residents and
among businesses
who actually taught there are there are
issues
thank you councillor fragile i'm not
seeing any other questions for you
so thank you i think now for members of
cabinet any questions
i think the portfolio holder would you
like to make make a response and then i
i have councillor harvey and we do have
julie lewis as the lead officer
available on screen
if there are any um operational
questions
so am i missing something mr grafton
i could see councillor junit with a hand
up
thank you councillor junaid i'll take
council harvey and then you
after councillor shenton
thank you leader um just to point out
that when we
had a conversation with the chair and
the deputy chair
on wednesday they accepted the results
of the survey they did not raise
any issues about lack of time to
to run them past the board at no point
did they
raise this they said they accepted the
results of the survey
as far as they were concerned any issues
over the market
was now a dead issue
and that's why they were not keen
to allow anyone to speak on their behalf
at that point in time
so they accept the results the chair and
the deputy chair that's what they
said to councillor jennings and myself
so
as far as i'm concerned i really don't
see
any need at this point in time to delay
this decision
any further we've already delayed it
twice
to allow them time to to put the survey
out
we do not need to delay this any time if
we delay it much further
we'll be at the point where we won't
have enough time to get it in front of
cabinet and council
and reviewing this this survey is not
going to change
anything those are the results what
what i it's unclear to me what it would
what it would achieve now
because those are the results
the board members that accept it and
or the the chair and the deputy chair
accept those results
you cannot suddenly drum up
another 100 people to go against it
you'd have to resurvey now that would
take two three four months then we would
be out
of time on the contract and then we
would have to re-negotiate we would be
into re-procurement
the stage now that's not a reason not to
consider the
the survey but i would i would pose the
question
that it serves what purpose would it
serve when the board
in the form of the chair and the deputy
chair accept the results
and they're not the only ones there are
room excuse me there are one a couple of
others
on the board who also have indicated
that they
accept this result and the market issue
is a dead issue as far as they're
concerned and there should be no further
delay
and no further talk about it this was
their words
not mine not councillor jennings but
their words
thank you councillor shenson councillor
harvey
um yeah i'm somewhat confused um
uh i i was going to simply i thought the
council frankly made a reasonable
request a little more time
what's the difference it would solve a
problem um i wasn't aware of the
explanation
that council of shenzhen just given that
the
this decision has already been delayed
for
twice and that there is seems to be
within
the bid or elements of the bid certainly
the chairman deputy chairman there seems
to be
a line that's been agreed um i'm
quite happy to go along despite the
the the the apparent reason this of what
cancer actually mentioned i'm quite
prepared to back my colleague
council shenton councillor junaid
the the request from the deferral seems
to be because
there there is a work relationship that
needs to be
improved uh and developed between the
bid
and the market whether this is deferred
or not
i would like to see that relationship be
improved so that we don't have um
any any problems the request by the
award member was for a short different
in order to apparently the the that
relationship
is improving and she wanted it to
the deferral to be for a short time in
order to cement that
improvement and relationshi of the in
relationship between those
two bodies um can i have some advice as
to
um whether there's any other way of
making sure that the relationship
improves i think i'm not sure there's
some legal advice i've been given i
think my observation counselor tune it
is that
um proceeding with the contractual
extension
is not mutually exclusive from the bid
and the market operator developing
more effective working relationships it
is a fact that the relationship between
the bid and the market
operator has not been as effective as it
should be for some considerable time
and any work to move the dial on that is
to be welcomed and undoubtedly would be
supported by
this authority and any member of this
authority who sits on the bid
board because that's in everybody's
interests
um i do know mr holford um
looking at the future prospects for
enhancements
and that has to be
welcomed again i'm not entirely
convinced that that there is a mutual
exclusivity between
what is being recommended here today and
further discussions down the line
not least of which because the shape of
this tan um
if noting the town cancels aspirations
under its neighborhood development plan
that of itself could have implications
further than the track
for the location shape size and um and
nature of markets in this town
um so i mean i think that of itself
um is is a future discussion i think
what we are
what we do have and i'm going to be
absolutely clear on this
i have i i i have an email from
uh the chair of the bid uh
dated uh last night uh and it is
absolutely clear that we have not had
the representation
formally of the bid as enunciated today
so
i'm probably not probably i am in the
space that says
i'll be supporting the recommendation
here so i'm going to open that up
to any further discussion uh or
questions for the portfolio holder
councillor jennings
yeah we're not discussing the pros and
cons of markets who gets on with each
other and who doesn't
we're discussing renewing or extending a
contract with an existing supplier
and i've seen no evidence to consider
changing suppliers
um and i don't see any objection from
the town council
from the district and it seems that the
vast majority
of the bid members because they haven't
they haven't written in to say that
they're against it
i don't see i don't see people who are
objecting to the way
the markets are being run um so i'm more
than happy to
to support this
council kettle um if i could ask
portfolio holder question i asked
councillor fragile earlier on
have you been presented with any
evidence from those two who
have provided data as the extent that
the markets
are damaging their businesses
the short answer to that is no um
that data hasn't been forthcoming um
we we have asked we did say
right at the outset that if they asked
that question
and they would provide the data we would
look seriously at it no
data has been forthcoming from those two
so we can only assume that they actually
don't want to share the data but
regardless of that it's two members
out of 420 members of the bid
we have to get that into some kind of
perspective
it's 92 percent okay any other debates
so the recommendation before before you
members
is outlined on page 55
as amended do you need that reading
actually are you all happy with the
amendment that
councillor shenton indicated you're all
happy that you know what you're voting
on
just for just for clarity and
transparency then councillor shenzhen
please re-read it
so the amended um recommendation is
subject to
stratfor town council approving this at
their meeting on the 27th of july
2021 the recommendation is that the
current market contract is extended
until the 30th of september
2027 and a new revenue and cost split
arrangement of 5050
be entered into by the head of service
in agreement with the portfolio holder
thank you councillor schenton all those
in favor please indicate
members cabinet that's unanimous
arising from overview and scrutiny
committee i don't think we have any
different
no no cabinet committee part part d
cabinet committees uh no items part e
on block items uh which are for note
um under the leadership leader
leadership and governance
portfolio the cabinet work program at
page 129
and the climate change panel at pages
141
part f are the matters urgent business
i've not been advised of any urgent
business
for the committee thank you
chief executive i therefore close this
meeting at
6 17 pm
you